I mean those people in Buffalo if they
have to deal with another wide right oh
you know what [__] them dude look at the
Lions the Lions went 0 and 16 haven't
sniffed a [__] Championship since the
1950s I have empathy for him and
everything like that but this whole
[__] thing is it the worst thing ever
to be a Buffalo Bills fan when I saw
that man in the crowd who was like look
he was in his late 20s early 30s just he
broke down crying oh dude I know I mean
that was [__] pathetic Paul the [__]
that I saw as a [__] Red Sox fan as a
Patriots fan as a Bruins fan growing up
yeah you didn't break down and cry now
listen we were walled off emotionally
but there has been an overcorrection in
the the American male the fact that that
guy could start pulling his hat down and
openly sobbing in public with a pom pom
hat on that's the kind of thing that
gets your country invaded dude the guy
was
like what the [__] pull it together oh
pull it together